i have four statements here and i want
you to think about which of these
statements are true and the first
statement is an object in motion will
slow down unless it is acted on by an
unbalanced force in the direction of
motion interesting second statement an
object in motion will maintain its speed
and direction forever unless acted on by
an unbalanced force also very
interesting third statement an object at
rest will stay at rest unless acted on
by an unbalanced force
and then the fort statement an object
acted on by an unbalanced force will
always accelerate in the direction of
the unbalanced force so i'll leave you
to think about those statements and
figure out which of those statements are
actually true it might be none of them
or it might be all of them or some
combination of them
now let's try to think about each of
these statements so first of all an
object in motion will slow down unless
it is acted on by an unbalanced force in
the direction of motion
well this at least on a first cut kind
of seems consistent with our everyday
experience if i'm pushing some furniture
across the room so let's say that this
is let's say this is the carpet of my
house and i'm pushing a television set
and let's say it's one of those
old-school heavy television sets
so i'm pushing a television set the only
way that i can keep it in motion is if i
keep pushing on it so let me draw my
force of pushing
my force of pushing so let's call that
right there the force of sal
pushing the television set so the only
way that i can keep the only way that i
can keep my television set moving it
seems like if i keep applying this
pushing force on it and if i were to
stop doing that it seems like it will
slow down so on a first cut everyday
experience this seems like it would
actually maybe be true but only seems
that way because i'm actually not
accounting for all of the forces in this
situation there's not just the force of
me pushing there's also the force of
friction there's also the force of
friction so i'll call that so there is
also the force of friction and if i want
to keep this tv moving at a constant
velocity my force of pushing let me make
that the vectors
look
about the same magnitude because they
need to be the same magnitude if i want
to keep my television set
at a constant velocity in the direction
that i'm pushing i have to exactly
offset the force of the force of
friction if my force of pushing is less
than the force of friction friction then
my the tv set will start to decelerate
if my force of pushing is larger than
the force of friction then my tv set
will accelerate but in this area
scenario right now i have an object in
motion but there's actually a balanced
force my pushing is completely balanced
by the force of friction another
scenario if we were to go into deep
space and i'm not even thinking about
air resistance right here but if we were
to go into space
where especially deep space no planets
around complete vacuum if an object is
in motion
if an object is in motion and there are
absolutely no
forces not balanced or otherwise there
are absolutely no forces acting on it
then that object is going to stay in
motion the only way that it might change
its direction or decelerate or
accelerate is if there is a net force on
it and just going back to this example
the only reason why it'll slow down if i
were to stop pushing is because there is
a net force on it the force of friction
and if you want to think about it would
probably be very a minor amount of air
resistance so this actually isn't true
an object in motion
does not have to slow down unless it's
acted on by an unbalanced force an
object in motion can stay in motion as
long as it's being acted on either by a
balanced force or or i guess or a set of
forces that balance each other or no
forces at all so this is not
that is not true
an object in motion will maintain its
speed and direction forever unless acted
on by an unbalanced force this is true
this is exactly what's happening right
over here
in the case of a i guess a block moving
through space in a vacuum if there are
no forces acting on it no net force is
acting on it it is not going to change
its velocity similarly you could have
this situation where you actually have
forces acting on it but they balance
each other out in this situation as long
as i could keep pushing forever and the
floor doesn't change and the so the
friction doesn't change this thing would
keep moving in that direction
theoretically forever the only way to
change its direction or accelerate it in
one direction or another direction would
be to have an unbalanced force so maybe
if my force of pushing were larger than
the force of friction or the force of
friction were larger than my force of
pushing so this right over here is
absolutely true
third statement an object at rest will
stay at rest unless acted on by an
unbalanced force and this is actually
pretty intuitive i think for people if
you just leave something alone if you
just leave something alone it's just
going to stay alone it's not going to
just start spontaneously moving and so
this is true and it's not just the
situation where there's no forces but it
could also be the situation that is
going to stay at rest
if there are balanced forces acting on
it and so the only way that you can
actually get this thing to come out of
that rest position is if you have a net
force an unbalanced force if let's say
that this force right here is much is is
i guess any amount larger than this
force right over here if they don't
completely balance out so this once
again is true
last statement an object acted on by an
unbalanced force will always accelerate
in the direction of the unbalanced force
so if i have an object and there's an
unbalanced force and if we net out all
the forces let's say the direction
is in
the force is net out and we get a force
acting in this direction this is
actually true the object will always
accelerate if it has an unbalanced force
acting on it in that direction it will
accelerate if there's a net force in
that direction
and there's another way of thinking
about it if you see an object that is
not accelerating like my tv that's
moving at a constant velocity or this
thing that's just traveling through
space if it if you see something that is
not accelerating that means that you
must that you ca there must not be an
unbalanced force acting on it you could
have balanced forces acting on it or you
could have no forces on it at all but
you can't have an unbalanced force if
you have an unbalanced force the thing
will be accelerating